una mezcla car Scooby est un Shh typique que
vous avez réussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
camote portabella par tina Palamo hey
Hachi nouvelle tâche de résidence observez un
vilain mod d Pocky mal spine le nouveau
Dawson fait pour Mulder
qui vous a raconté edom presque temps
venir Ellis Jose  Caicos Oussama je peux
prendre une valve à vapeur est n'importe quoi
mon pote haletant à nouveau
si je suis perdu
bienvenue
non elle vaut mieux à peu près ça
bonjour
[Musique]
mademoiselle Martha bien sûr cette partition Hotel
des cycles ECM à propos de ton oncle
Zack handicap démontrable  service
parce que W dans l'objet supérieur hier
se
lever tout est devenu la meilleure nouvelle de la nuit
Monica elle a de la merde a duré elle était
bien de retour chacune des balles va
problème oncle
acide classique
euh allez machiniste à mon anus
Oh
toi
[Musique]
et puis ça  complètement évité mais seulement
si pour la partie réorganiser Savanti ACO
schewe ne remet pas en question j'ai dit Richard et
tout cela conclut que retour
[Musique]
B&E opposition Mishimoto
dit expressio  n ratina monstro moi Oh L
producción moi fils Dieu Oh compagnie moonsto
perdón por esta lección les sermons sont
au sommet d'un ascenseur pas la vieillesse aucune
entreprise dire pour chacun je préfère su propia
el telefono donc la présence d'exactitude en
particulier politique officier LeMat mr.
Lee l'a remarqué Linda Isaac Jaffee
méditation Allah et Allah présente
Anakin comme vous pouvez le voir votre honte est un
mushrik c'est un amateur à l'heure actuelle vous
n'avez aucune idée de ce que vous avez découvert mais
je pense vraiment que le grand film de monstres est séparé
des autres films d'horreur typiques
est que  il y a un véritable investissement émotionnel profond
dans les personnages
les hiéroglyphes disent qu'elle a été nommée
Almanac choisie pour être la prochaine reine d'Egypte
c'est une princesse qui a promis de
devenir pharaon mais ensuite tout ce qui lui a
été enlevé ah Manette passe
par une énorme série de transformations
nous '  Je ne l'ai pas sortie en cinq étapes
La première étape, elle n'est rien d'autre que des chiffons d'os
, puis elle nous rassemble
littéralement dans cette forme alors qu'elle commence
à se nourrir,
il est la vraie
Sofia parfaitement interprétée comme la momie, son
âme n'est pas ses yeux et elle peut '  Je ne le cache
pas et c'est son cadeau tout ce qu'elle a à faire
est de regarder la caméra et vous êtes
immédiatement arrêté Je pensais qu'il n'y avait littéralement
personne d'autre sur la planète qui pouvait jouer
ce rôle et le  la façon dont elle bouge
physiquement est incroyable Dominus c'est une
guerrière
ce projet m'a permis de repousser mes limites
[Musique] l'
un des grands vieux adages est que le
méchant est le héros de sa propre histoire Je
pense que vous vous connecterez si profondément à
son expérience  dans ce qu'elle a
traversé parce que donc Fiat était incroyable
avec cette maman femme quelle est ton histoire
ça attire mon attention je veux voir ce
film tu ne peux pas t'échapper
elle a des plans pour toi
ouais on a des dents et la maman va
avoir super  l'action et les vrais frissons
voulaient être sauvages et violents et
erratiques et spontanés avoir Tom
Cruise dans ce film est tellement énorme pour nous que
cela change complètement le jeu son
énergie est contagieuse il doit se surpasser
chaque fois que je maximise sa
passion sa conduite son  la détermination
éclaire le chemin pour nous tous, il vous remplit
de cet enthousiasme d'enfance où
vous êtes comme si je voulais faire le film
que Tom voit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Tom, il est vraiment bon pour pousser pour garder
le vrai  Mike Jenelle Republic me claque à
nouveau la tête Tom est dans le véhicule et ouais
ça me fait mal parce que c'est un
bon conducteur et c'est un conducteur rapide.
Je viens de découvrir que je vais courir sur un
bâtiment qui s'effondre à tout moment, débranchez
celui-ci madhu un renflouement et
il va y avoir cette montée d'adrénaline
et vous allez adorer ça et ensuite vous
allez tout faire  bon allons-y encore oh
allons-y encore il a adoré nous
traversons la gravité à l'intérieur d'un vrai avion Tom
repousse toujours les limites et c'est l'
une des valeurs mais ouais Tom fait ressortir
le meilleur de tout le monde il est dans un sans couture
et il apporte chaque once  d'énergie qu'il
a pour sa performance, je me suis senti très courageux
autour de lui,
il a inspiré une bravoure et c'est
un cadeau incroyable pour donner à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
vu quelqu'un s'engager dans ma vie
que tout le monde soit vraiment fier de
l'effort qu'il a déployé pour faire quelque chose
de qu  alité qui signifie beaucoup pour moi
rire dans le monde mais qui pourrait trouver
le VI venir ici ensemble comme si c'était
vraiment fait
toi